tout patient pour la gauche ne remporte
pas cette élection moi ce qui me plaît
beaucoup dans les débats c'est que les
candidats qui ne gagnent pas sont
toujours très contente du score qu'ils
font et notamment monsieur dugourd ici
présente très bien monsieur que vous
n'ayez jamais fait depuis que vous êtes
candidat c'est le plus beau des sports
que vous n'ayez jamais fait et je
voudrais expliquer aux électeurs du
rasoir différents toi parce qu'à force
de faire du pied des clins d'oeil au
front national
vous êtes dépassés sur votre droite vous
êtes dépassés sur votre droite parce que
vous n'avez pas arrêté de faire alors
une campagne en parlant de la fraude
sociale
en en parlant de sécurité résultat des
courses vous êtes aujourd'hui talonné
par le front national
talonné par le front national vous avez
sur dijon 3 une triangulaire avec le
front national
vous même vous êtes en difficulté vous
avez certainement gagné mais un front
national mais c'est va devoir voter pour
vous attendez et et et à force de faire
des clins d'oeil au front national
eh bien vous vous trouvez aujourd'hui
même monsieur sauvadet se retrouve
contre le front national aujourd'hui et
à dijon nous résistons et nous résistons
bien et ça c'est grâce à la politique
qui est menée par françois rebsamen en
premier temps et à et alain millot à
s'il meurt à la suite les gens faut pas
prendre les électeurs pour des imbéciles
1 ils comprennent bien les élus de
terrain ils savent ce que c'est quand
ils sont sur place
qui s'occupe d'eux et serra et votent
pour eux et c'est ce qui se passe à
dijon aujourd'hui mais croyez moi
d'ailleurs on le voit dans toute la
france mais entre dans le département à
force de faire du pied au front national
vous êtes en train de vous faire
dépasser par le front national